Hi, it's Paola from Italy.
嗨，我是来自意大利的保拉。
The first time I watched Alma Mater was during the first wave of COVID that came March 2020.
我第一次看《母校》是在 2020 年 3 月第一波新冠疫情期间。
My name is Josh.
我叫乔什。
I first watched the show as a college student in New York.
我第一次看这个节目时还是纽约的一名大学生。
My name is Anna.
我叫安娜。
I am in Los Angeles, planet Earth.
我在地球洛杉矶。
How I met your mother is special because, whether I've had a fantastic day or a f***ing terrible day, watching that show is always the right move for the mid.
我遇见你母亲的方式很特别，因为无论我度过了美好的一天还是糟糕透顶的一天，观看那个节目始终是中间的正确选择。
My friend told me to watch the show and just said, I'm Ted Mosby.
我的朋友让我看这个节目并只是说，我是特德·莫斯比。
he's talking about, and I watched it and I came back to him and I said, mm-hmm, I'm dead mostly.
他正在谈论，我看着它，然后我回到他身边，我说，嗯嗯，我基本上已经死了。
You remember, it was hard time with strict lockdowns, isolation.
你记得，那是一段艰难的时期，严格的封锁和隔离。
After a very tough day, every night, I watched some of my episodes to, let's say, overcome such difficult times.
在经历了非常艰难的一天之后，每天晚上，我都会观看一些剧集，以克服这样的困难时期。
It feels right, regardless, to go spend time with those characters, those candid, stumbling, hilarious, raunchy, relentlessly then selves people, and that gives the same feeling, the same quality of what good friendship is.
不管怎样，和那些坦率的、跌跌撞撞的、热闹的、不修边幅的、无情的人一起度过时光的感觉是对的，这给了同样的感觉，同样的品质，就像良好的友谊一样。
And being between junior and senior year of college, I was terrified of what was coming next and how to make it happen the way I want.
在大学三年级和四年级之间，我对接下来发生的事情以及如何让它按照我想要的方式发生感到恐惧。
Then there was this wonderful show that was all about how the randomness of life is what gets you exactly where you need to be.
然后有一个精彩的节目，讲述的是生活的随机性如何让你准确地到达你需要去的地方。
I'll be soon in New York City, when I see you.
当我见到你时，我很快就会到纽约。
Please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
请允许我告诉你纽约市的一切。
Well, hello, hello.
嗯，你好，你好。
This is Josh Radner.
这是乔什·拉德纳。
I am here with my friend Craig Thomas.
我和我的朋友克雷格·托马斯在这里。
Hi, Josh.
嗨，乔什。
Hey, it's great to be here with you.
嘿，很高兴和你在一起。
Welcome to the first episode of How We Made Your Mother.
欢迎收看《我们如何成就了你的母亲》第一集。
Are we calling it Wimium?
我们称之为 Wimium 吗？
I was wondering about that, Hwimium.
我很好奇这个问题，Hwimium。
I think it's Hwimium.
我认为是 Hwimium。
Does it work?
有效吗？
I think it does.
我认为确实如此。
So how I make your mother, which is the show under discussion, is a show that ran on CBS from 2005 to 2014, is that right, Craig?
那么，我如何让你的母亲，即正在讨论的节目，成为哥伦比亚广播公司 (CBS) 2005 年至 2014 年播出的节目，对吗，克雷格？
That is correct, nine seasons.
没错，九季。
Nine seasons.
九个季节。
So almost a decade of our lives, I played the eye in how I make your mother, I played the character of Ted Mosby for nine seasons and Craig tell us what you did on the show.
在我们生命的近十年里，我扮演了如何塑造你母亲的角色，我扮演了泰德·莫斯比这个角色九季，克雷格告诉我们你在剧中做了什么。
I was Barney.
我是巴尼。
No, that's right, I remember that.
不，是这样，我记得。
I have not aged well if you're watching on the YouTube.
如果你在 YouTube 上观看的话，我还没有老好。
No, I'm the co-creator of the show, along with my very brilliant writing partner, Carter Bees, who will be a guest on here to discuss future and future episodes.
不，我是该剧的共同创作者，还有我非常出色的编剧搭档卡特比斯，他将作为嘉宾在这里讨论未来和未来的剧集。
And we were lucky enough to create the show that found our way to the likes of you, Mr. Ratner.
拉特纳先生，我们很幸运能够制作出这样的节目，并受到了像您这样的人的喜爱。
Oh, thanks.
哦，谢谢。
Well, Craig and I have obviously been friends now for coming on two decades, which is astonishing.
嗯，克雷格和我显然已经是二十年来的朋友了，这真是令人惊讶。
We both now live in New York.
我们现在都住在纽约。
About once a year, I would say, we have a habit of grabbing a meal or some drinks and talk inevitably turns to how I made my mother as well as other things that are happening in our lives.
我想说，大约每年一次，我们都有吃顿饭或喝点饮料的习惯，谈话不可避免地会转向我如何创造我的母亲以及我们生活中发生的其他事情。
But I so enjoy talking about how I made my mother with you and unpacking this thing we made that has been the biggest gift and has carried a lot of shadow with it.
但我非常喜欢谈论我如何与你一起创造我的母亲，并打开我们制作的这个东西的包装，它是最大的礼物，并带有很多阴影。
It's just like all things is a very complicated thing, but also a very beautiful thing.
就好像一切事物都是一件很复杂的事情，但同时也是一件很美好的事情。
And you're the person I love talking about this show with the most.
你是我最喜欢谈论这个节目的人。
So when this idea struck me like, you know what?
所以当我想到这个想法时，你知道吗？
It's actually time for me to turn around and revisit how I met your mother but also watch it a lot of the episodes for the first time.
实际上，我是时候回过头来回顾一下我是如何认识你母亲的，但也第一次观看了很多剧集。
I only watched about half the episodes, what it was on.
我只看了大约一半的剧集，内容是什么。
So I will be rewatching the show along with you and our listeners, some of whom I assume will be coming to the show for the first time.
因此，我将与您和我们的听众一起重新观看该节目，我认为其中一些人将是第一次观看该节目。
Other ones will have watched it many times and are just looking for the backstage notes here.
其他人可能已经看过很多次了，只是在这里寻找后台笔记。
But I figured if I'm gonna do this, why don't we put it on the record and actually just walk through the show together and much like the older wiser narrator Ted, which we are now around that age.
但我想，如果我要这样做，为什么我们不把它记录下来，实际上只是一起走过这个节目，就像年长而明智的叙述者泰德一样，我们现在已经在这个年纪了。
Let's look back and see who we were, who we are now, where we're going.
让我们回顾一下，看看我们曾经是谁，现在是谁，我们要去哪里。
And yeah, what else would you say about what we're doing here?
是的，对于我们在这里所做的事情，您还有什么想说的吗？
Well, first of all, I can't believe you only watched half of the episodes, I'm deeply offended.
好吧，首先，我不敢相信你只看了一半的剧集，我被深深冒犯了。
I think I'm just gonna walk off.
我想我要走开
I'm walking off the project.
我要离开这个项目了。
No, the truth is, I haven't rewatched the show door to door since it went off.
不，事实是，自从节目结束后我就没有挨家挨户地重看过。
I've seen episodes, but I haven't watched the door to door.
我看过几集，但没挨家挨户看过。
And so I think what we're doing here is excavating back into our past.
所以我认为我们在这里所做的就是挖掘我们的过去。
It was almost a decade of our lives.
这几乎是我们生命中的十年。
And we're trying to figure out what did we do there?
我们试图弄清楚我们在那里做了什么？
What happened?
发生了什么？
We made this thing.
我们做了这个东西。
It's like the pineapple episode.
这就像菠萝情节。
You're like, we have to piece it together.
你说，我们必须把它拼凑起来。
We're doing the pineapple incident.
我们正在处理菠萝事件。
but for the entire series, what happened?
但对于整个系列来说，发生了什么？
We woke up, we woke up, we were, we were waking up, we're almost 50 or I think you're, you're there and I'm almost there and we're kind of going, wait, we are closer to the age of future Ted, we are closer to 2030 than we were to do then we are to 2005 when the show launched.
我们醒了，我们醒了，我们醒了，我们快醒了，我们快50岁了，或者我想你快到了，我也快到了，我们正在走，等等，我们离未来特德的年龄更近了，我们比节目开播时的2005年更接近2030年。
And it is just, it is strange.
这就是，这很奇怪。
I was thinking about the sort of symmetry of it.
我在思考它的对称性。
We are something like, I think 20 years since the premiere, I think this September will be 20 years since the premiere.
我们就像是，我想自首映以来已有 20 年了，我认为今年 9 月将是自首映以来 20 年。
We are just past 10 years of the finale airing, a bit of finishing airing.
我们距离大结局播出已经过去了 10 年，算是收尾播出了。
So there's a lot of round numbers.
所以有很多整数。
There's a 20 and there's a 10 and here we are.
有一个 20，有一个 10，我们到了。
And it just seems like a good moment to kind of look back and take stock of it.
这似乎是回顾和评估它的好时机。
Yeah, I, um, another thing that I, when I called you to talk about this, that I really wanted to talk about, I said, I am astonished one at the, the kind of long tail of the show.
是的，我，嗯，当我打电话给你谈论这个时，我真的很想谈论另一件事，我说，我对这部剧的长尾感到惊讶。
You know, a lot of shows go off the air and, and they go off the air, they go away, you know, and maybe they come up randomly in a, I don't know, trivia night or a, you know, remember that a moment will come back to you.
你知道，很多节目都停播了，然后它们停播了，它们就消失了，你知道，也许它们会在一个我不知道的琐事之夜中随机出现，或者一个你知道的，记住某个时刻你会回来。
But there's something about how I made Mother One.
但我是如何制作《母亲一号》的。
It keeps minting new fans.
它不断地吸引新的粉丝。
So people that were babies, children, or even in their teens when it was on, have now discovered it.
因此，当它出现时，婴儿、儿童甚至青少年的人们现在都发现了它。
I also think there's a really sweet thing.
我也觉得有一个非常甜蜜的事情。
I think parents are showing it to their teenage kids now.
我认为父母现在正在向十几岁的孩子展示它。
They're like, this show taught me a lot about being an adult or young adult navigating all these things.
他们就像，这个节目教会了我很多关于作为一个成年人或年轻人如何应对所有这些事情的知识。
But also, I'm astonished at a number of things, but one of the ones that strikes me about when I hear from how I made my mother fans, something I hear so consistently that it's not just anecdotal.
而且，我对很多事情感到惊讶，但其中一件让我震惊的是，当我听到我如何让我的母亲成为粉丝时，我一直听到这样的事情，这不仅仅是轶事。
It has to be, there has to be something there, which is that people say I got turned onto the show or I started watching the show when I was in a really hard moment of my life, whether it's, you know, I was going through a divorce or a sickness or my parent had died.
一定是这样，一定有什么东西，那就是人们说我开始看这个节目，或者我在人生中非常困难的时刻开始看这个节目，无论是，你知道，我正在经历离婚、生病还是我的父母去世了。
I was having a personal kind of moment of crisis and there seems to be that this thing I've noticed that how I met your mother is like soul medicine for people going through hard times.
我正经历着个人的危机时刻，我注意到我如何遇见你母亲这件事似乎对于经历困难时期的人来说就像灵魂良药。
And I don't know that it was conceived of that.
我不知道它是这样构想的。
Exactly, I don't think you and Carter sat down in 2004 and said, I know what we'll do.
确切地说，我不认为你和卡特在 2004 年坐下来说，我知道我们会做什么。
We'll do a soul panacea for people.
我们将为人们做灵魂灵丹妙药。
But it seems like that's what it does for people.
但这似乎就是它对人们的作用。
And I hear it so consistently that it strikes me as something worth exploring.
我经常听到它，这让我觉得它是值得探索的东西。
It's such an honor.
真是太荣幸了。
People come up to us all the time and to you, Josh, and say the show got them through something really hard.
人们总是来找我们，也来找你，乔什，说这部剧帮助他们度过了一些非常困难的时期。
And getting that, or they say I married my wife because we realized we're both how much mother fans.
得到这个，或者他们说我娶了我的妻子，因为我们意识到我们都是妈妈的粉丝。
So they met in an event or something, like it's just the ways the show has been crucial in people's lives, like the opening words from the fans.
所以他们是在一次活动或其他事情中相遇的，就像这就是这部剧对人们生活至关重要的方式，就像粉丝们的开场白一样。
We have the greatest fans of any fans.
我们拥有所有粉丝中最伟大的粉丝。
How much more the fans are?
粉丝还有多少？
Shout out to the fans.
向粉丝们喊话。
Huge shout out to the fans.
向粉丝们大声喊叫。
If you were listening to this, you were an amazing person.
如果你听到这个，你就是一个了不起的人。
And I find such an openness, Josh, to come talk to us about stuff.
乔什，我发现自己很愿意来和我们谈论一些事情。
Do you get this?
你明白吗？
I get this a little bit because I'm a writer and people I have to go around telling people, I wear a little shirt that says I create a how much mother and just you got in that needy.
我有点明白这一点，因为我是一名作家，我必须到处告诉人们，我穿着一件小衬衫，上面写着我创造了一个母亲，你为那个有需要的人提供了多少。
But no one knows, I have a tattooed on my face.
但没有人知道，我脸上有纹身。
You have 10 most of me tattooed on your face.
你脸上纹了10个我的大部分。
And I've been dying for years to ask you, this sort of two-part question, what was it like being Ted when the show was on and blowing up and not being able to escape Ted's face, your face is dead space, although you are not Ted.
多年来我一直很想问你，这种由两部分组成的问题，当节目播出并爆炸时，作为泰德感觉如何，无法逃脱泰德的脸，你的脸是死气沉沉的空间，尽管你不是泰德。
And then, what does that felt like kind of in the long 10 years since it went off the air?
那么，自从它停播以来的漫长十年里，感觉怎么样？
What does that felt like?
那感觉怎么样？
The reason I thought of that is that you just said people come up to you and they share these things with you.
我这么想的原因是你刚才说人们来找你并与你分享这些事情。
That seems like a real gift.
这看起来像是一份真正的礼物。
I'm sure there's also like like enormous, weird downsides, don't they?
我确信还有一些巨大的、奇怪的缺点，不是吗？
Oh, yeah.
哦，是的。
Do it, do it.
做吧，做吧。
It's such an interesting thing.
这是一件非常有趣的事情。
Let's do a little tighter episode on being Ted Mosby.
让我们以泰德·莫斯比 (Ted Mosby) 的身份做一个更紧凑的剧集。
I think there's a lot to unpack that I wouldn't be able to unpack here, but I'll do a little bit of it.
我认为有很多东西需要解开，但我无法在这里解开，但我会做一些。
I will say this.
我会这么说。
I remember I was writing liberal arts for the second film I wrote and directed.
我记得我正在为我自编自导的第二部电影撰写文科文章。
And it was 2009 or 10.
那是2009年或10年。
I think it was 2010.
我认为那是2010年。
And I went to Spain for a month.
我去了西班牙一个月。
Kicked around Spain, went to about five or six cities, wrote during the day and kind of just got into trouble at night on some level.
在西班牙各地闲逛，去了大约五六个城市，白天写作，晚上在某种程度上遇到了麻烦。
I mean, it was just really fun.
我的意思是，这真的很有趣。
And my friend, Horula, introduced me to all her friends who were living in Spain.
我的朋友霍鲁拉把我介绍给她所有住在西班牙的朋友。
So I had like these blind friend dates everywhere.
所以我到处都有这样的盲人朋友约会。
But I would leave my hotel or wherever I was staying.
但我会离开我的酒店或我住的地方。
And I would people, I was just getting recognized in Spain.
我想人们，我刚刚在西班牙得到认可。
And people would want a picture.
人们想要一张照片。
They want to say, hi, but then they'd so say, do you want to come to a flamenco show in a couple hours?
他们想说，嗨，但他们会说，你想在几个小时后来看一场弗拉门戈表演吗？
And I'd say yes.
我会说是的。
And it was like my face was this like social I don't know like the fact that they were familiar with me gave them permission it like it was just this weird social lubricant that I was I was accepted everywhere I was it one of the things I really loved about it made the world feel much smaller right you know I've always wanted to not I don't want to talk to every person I meet but I do like the feeling that the world is not so big again filled with anonymous, scary people.
我的脸就像是社交的，我不知道他们对我的熟悉这一事实给了他们许可，就像这只是一种奇怪的社交润滑剂，我在任何地方都被接受，这是我真正喜欢的事情之一，它让世界感觉更小，你知道的，我一直想，不是我不想和我遇到的每个人交谈，但我确实喜欢这种感觉，世界不再那么大，充满了匿名的、可怕的人。
Because I find people are, most people are quite lovely once you get to know them, once you get over that, kind of like your strange endeavor, I don't know who you are or where you're from.
因为我发现大多数人都是很可爱的，一旦你了解了他们，一旦你克服了这一点，有点像你奇怪的努力，我不知道你是谁，也不知道你来自哪里。
Yeah.
是的。
So it gave me like a common language with people.
所以它给了我与人们的共同语言。
I think I've told you this, but in Spain, I went to this little town called Daya and I got really sick.
我想我已经告诉过你了，但在西班牙，我去了一个叫达亚的小镇，我病得很厉害。
I got food poisoning for the first 24 hours and I crawled out of the place I was staying And I had hooded sweatshirt on that.
我在最初的 24 小时内食物中毒，然后我爬出了我住的地方，我穿着连帽运动衫。
I think it was like tied.
我认为这就像捆绑一样。
And I was just trying to get like some ginger ale or something and some crackers because I was so, I was such a mess.
我只是想喝点姜汁汽水之类的东西和一些饼干，因为我实在是太糟糕了。
And there were like 10 or 12 like young college students.
大概有十到十二个年轻的大学生。
They were hotel management interns from like all over the world.
他们是来自世界各地的酒店管理实习生。
And they recognized me like through my hoodie with this sickness.
他们通过我的连帽衫认出了我，因为我得了这种病。
And they were like, Oh, that's him.
他们就像，哦，那就是他。
It must be vomiting in a bush.
一定是在灌木丛中呕吐。
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
是的，是的，完全正确。
And they invited me the next night to either come to launch or dinner I forget.
第二天晚上他们邀请我来参加发布会或者共进晚餐，我忘了。
but I ended up hanging out with these hotel management interns for like three or four days and they were incredible.
但我最终和这些酒店管理实习生一起待了大约三四天，他们非常棒。
But this one guy owned the bar and we were in Mallorca and he owned the bar.
但这个人拥有这家酒吧，而我们在马略卡岛，他拥有这家酒吧。
To be clear, not the bar that gave you food poisoning.
需要明确的是，不是让你食物中毒的酒吧。
No, no, no, he wasn't.
不，不，不，他不是。
I got food poisoning in another town.
我在另一个城镇食物中毒了。
He was 23 years old.
那年他23岁。
His dad had just died and so he inherited this bar.
他的父亲刚刚去世，所以他继承了这个酒吧。
He had never been off the island of Mallorca.
他从未离开过马略卡岛。
One night he hands me a drink and he says, no-can-doze-filled baby doll, and he knew every single line of how I met your mother.
有一天晚上，他递给我一杯饮料，他说，这是一个不能打瞌睡的娃娃，他知道我是如何认识你母亲的每一句话。
That's so amazing.
太神奇了。
And the thing he told me that I thought was so spectacular was he said, how I met your mother has taught me that what's happening now will be my memories one day.
他告诉我的那件事让我觉得非常壮观，他说，我是如何认识你母亲的，这告诉我，现在发生的事情有一天会成为我的回忆。
So make sure that the present moment is great, that you're making good memories for yourself in the present moment, you know.
因此，请确保当下时刻是美好的，确保你在当下时刻为自己创造美好的回忆，你知道。
And then these hotel management interns, for some reason, like, you know, they would, they would have a few drinks in them, but they would tell me like their deepest, darkest secrets, like some shocking stuff.
然后这些酒店管理实习生，出于某种原因，比如，你知道，他们会喝一些饮料，但他们会告诉我他们最深、最黑暗的秘密，比如一些令人震惊的事情。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think there was something about they knew me.
我认为他们有些了解我。
They felt like they knew.
他们感觉自己知道了。
They felt comfortable with it.
他们对此感到很舒服。
Yeah, that's it.
是的，就是这样。
This is not an invitation.
这不是邀请。
By the way, if you're hearing this to come up to me, it's about your job.
顺便说一句，如果你听到我说这件事，那是关于你的工作的。
Tell you really weird.
告诉你真的很奇怪。
So let's beat your dishes.
所以让我们来打败你的菜吧。
Let's have boundaries.
让我们有界限。
But there is something about this, this is the kind of stuff I really love is it gave me like, like access to people in a way that made the world feel friendly.
但这是我真正喜欢的东西，因为它让我能够以一种让世界感到友好的方式接触人们。
That's a beautiful story.
这是一个美丽的故事。
That is a key.
那是一把钥匙。
You have like the skeleton key to let you into doors that would not have been open.
你就像一把万能钥匙，可以让你进入那些原本不会打开的门。
And I wrote you this little ditty to sing to you in New York City.
我给你写了这首小曲，是为了在纽约唱给你听。
We'll be right back and now back to the show.
我们马上回来，现在回到演出​​。
It Ted is a complicated character, he's a complicated character to have played because he's the eyes and ears, he's the center of the show, he's the person that kind of welcomes the audience in, but he was also his own really flawed, dimensional character and I have found the people who relate to Ted are unbelievably fascinating to me.
泰德是一个复杂的角色，他是一个复杂的角色，因为他是眼睛和耳朵，他是节目的中心，他是那种欢迎观众的人，但他也是他自己真正有缺陷的、立体的角色，我发现与泰德有关的人对我来说令人难以置信的着迷。
Just as many women come up to me and say, I'm like Ted as men, which is really incredible.
就像很多女人来找我说，我就像男人一样，这真的很不可思议。
But just like people who are worried they feel a little too much, you know, Ted was probably a HSPs at a highly sensitive person.
但就像那些担心自己感觉有点太多的人一样，你知道，特德可能是一个高度敏感的人的 HSP。
I think that's fair to say.
我认为这样说是公平的。
And he just had a big heart and it sometimes got in the way of social, you know, what was expected of him.
他只是有一颗宽广的心，有时这会妨碍社交，你知道，人们对他的期望。
But I just, you know, it's an honor to have played someone that kind of raw, right, whose nerve endings were so exposed, and it helped me, you know, it helped me become more vulnerable and, you know, disclose parts of myself that maybe I was embarrassed about that I, that you guys were demanding that they be front and center.
但我只是，你知道，很荣幸能够扮演那种原始的人，对，他的神经末梢如此暴露，这帮助了我，你知道，它帮助我变得更加脆弱，你知道，暴露了我自己的一部分，也许我对我感到尴尬，你们要求他们站在最前面和中心。
also like be even at that time, you know, 2005, like to be a publicly vulnerable male.
甚至在那个时候，你知道，2005年，也喜欢成为一个公开的弱势男性。
Yeah.
是的。
It's still carrying risks, you know, how about now, too?
它仍然存在风险，你知道，现在也一样吗？
I mean, it's, it carries risks, yeah, but it was like a big grave thing you guys asked of me and I'm, and I'm grateful and I'm glad that it resonates with people and continues to.
我的意思是，它有风险，是的，但这就像你们向我提出的一件大事，我很感激，我很高兴它能引起人们的共鸣，并继续下去。
And it's, it's funny.
这很有趣。
But you said about being vulnerable because it was vulnerable to right, too.
但你提到脆弱是因为它也容易受到权利的影响。
Carder and I are these like super emo, like sort of we are highly sensitive people.
卡德和我都是超级情绪化的人，就像我们是高度敏感的人一样。
We wear our hearts on our sleeves.
我们把我们的心挂在袖子上。
We have big dreams like Ted.
我们像特德一样有远大的梦想。
The creation of this show, when we were 30 years old, that was a far-fetched impossible dream to create this show.
这个节目的创作，在我们30岁的时候，创作这个节目是一个遥不可及的不可能的梦想。
That was us Tedmos being all over the place, coming up with some big far-fetched plan that should never have worked out.
那是我们泰德莫到处乱搞，想出了一些根本不应该实现的宏大的牵强计划。
But somehow it did demanding that it rain and somehow it worked out not in all the ways we thought it would, which is the same story for Ted.
但不知何故，它确实要求下雨，但不知何故，结果并不像我们想象的那样，这对特德来说也是同样的故事。
It never goes exactly how you plan, but it becomes beautiful in some different way than you you ever could have imagined that was the show, what's funny is, Carter and I are very much like that.
它永远不会完全按照你的计划进行，但它会以某种不同于你想象的方式变得美丽，这就是演出，有趣的是，卡特和我非常喜欢那样。
Marshall's a really sweet, emotional, open-hearted, warm, softy of a guy.
马歇尔是一个非常可爱、情绪化、心胸开阔、热情、柔软的人。
He's basically had one girlfriend who became his wife, and we would get these notes early on sometimes from well-meaning executives.
他基本上有一个女朋友后来成为了他的妻子，有时我们会很早就从善意的高管那里收到这些笔记。
Early, and before the show was launched, probably before we even cast it, but also maybe early in the run, where we get these notes, the characters were so based on us at first, right?
早期，在节目推出之前，可能在我们选角之前，但也可能在运行的早期，我们得到这些笔记，角色一开始就是以我们为基础的，对吧？
And then it became like creating it with you guys, But if first it really was us, and we would get these notes from executives, it would be the effect of like, these guys are just such fucking whims.
然后就变成了和你们一起创造它，但如果首先真的是我们，我们会从高管那里得到这些笔记，那就会产生这样的效果，这些家伙就是这么他妈的突发奇想。
That's how it felt.
就是这样的感觉。
It was just like, we would get notes that to the effect of like, no man would ever, no man would call himself a man.
就像，我们会收到这样的注释，大意是，没有人会，没有人会称自己为男人。
Self-respecting man would ever behave in this way.
有自尊心的人永远都会这样做。
We're like, um, well, that's based on something that I did.
我们就像，嗯，嗯，这是基于我所做的事情。
And it was really, really weird.
这真的非常非常奇怪。
And I think it was my little glimpse at probably how it felt to you in literally your body, embodying the character.
我认为这可能是我对你身体的感受的一点小小的瞥见，体现了这个角色。
Yeah.
是的。
And you had to sort of carry that.
你必须随身携带它。
The MTV show Jackass, you were doing that with your heart on CBS every Monday night.
MTV 节目《Jackass》，每周一晚上你都会在 CBS 上用心做这件事。
You were just like, what happens if we push Ted's heart off a cliff in a shopping cart?
你就像，如果我们用购物车把特德的心推下悬崖，会发生什么？
Let's see what happens.
让我们看看会发生什么。
And it's just like there was kind of a stunt and emotional stuntman quality to that.
这就像有一种特技和情感特技演员的品质。
And you were kind of doing your own stunts.
你有点像在做自己的特技。
yeah, especially when there's so much confusion between, you know, you know, you play a character and especially if it's the first introduction to you, you know, I didn't have a lot of public things, but I mean, I had pilots and series that didn't go anywhere.
是的，尤其是当你扮演一个角色之间存在如此多的混乱时，特别是如果这是对你的第一次介绍，你知道，我没有太多公开的东西，但我的意思是，我的试播集和系列没有任何进展。
And so this is where people kind of met me.
这就是人们遇见我的地方。
So they thought, well, this is who this is, you know, I do remember at the beginning of, I think, second or third season, but I don't remember which one, but no, I was beginning of third season and you guys wanted to really send Ted and Barney out on a lot of adventures.
所以他们想，嗯，这就是这个人，你知道，我确实记得在第二季或第三季的开头，但我不记得是哪一个，但不，我在第三季开始时，你们真的想让泰德和巴尼出去进行很多冒险。
And you started writing Ted as a little more Barney-ish in terms of like he was open to like one night stands and all this stuff.
你开始把泰德写得更像巴尼，因为他对一夜情和所有这些事情都持开放态度。
And I remember Pam told me that you guys got a note that said, you know, there's a lot of Barney's on TV, but there's only one Ted.
我记得帕姆告诉我，你们收到一张纸条，上面写着，电视上有很多巴尼的角色，但只有一个特德。
Let's keep him.
我们留住他吧。
Let's preserve his his tendness or his most-beeness.
让我们保留他的温柔或最善良。
Yeah, totally.
是的，完全可以。
And we had a lot of really smart, strong, female voices from this video and the network who really got the emotion by the show, and we're kind of guardians of that.
我们从这个视频和网络中得到了很多非常聪明、强大的女性声音，她们真正从节目中感受到了情感，我们是这一点的守护者。
And that doesn't always happen.
但这并不总是发生。
And that was really nice.
那真是太好了。
And it's not like that fit in with every other show on the network at the time.
这并不适合当时网络上的所有其他节目。
And that was preserved and it was what was beautiful about the show.
这一点被保留了下来，这就是这场演出的美妙之处。
And thank God.
感谢上帝。
Yeah.
是的。
I wanted to do a quick little pause and just say, our producer, Alec Lev, are wonderful and heroic producer without whom we wouldn't be doing this show.
我想稍微停顿一下，然后说，我们的制片人亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）是一位出色而英勇的制片人，没有他我们就不会做这个节目。
Well, chime in from time to time with a question or guidance.
好吧，时不时地提出问题或指导。
Thank you guys for for for bringing me into this.
谢谢你们让我参与其中。
And I'm excited to be on the journey with you.
我很高兴能与您一起踏上旅程。
And yeah, you might hear some questions from me.
是的，你可能会听到我的一些问题。
My first one here if I could just throw one in, Josh is, why now?
这是我的第一个，如果我可以扔一个进去，乔希是，为什么现在呢？
Why now?
为什么是现在？
You've had 10 years podcasts have been around.
播客已经存在 10 年了。
You've been thinking about this show and then all of a sudden, Craig got the call and then I got the call.
你一直在考虑这个节目，然后突然间，克雷格接到了电话，然后我也接到了电话。
You'd like to think about this now.
你现在想考虑一下这个问题。
And I'm wondering what, Josh, I hope that this answer will include your, your lovely new wife because I'm, I'm eager to talk about that spark of it all too.
我想知道什么，乔什，我希望这个答案将包括你，你可爱的新妻子，因为我，我也渴望谈论这一切的火花。
Yeah.
是的。
Well, I did get married a year ago, almost exactly a year ago.
嗯，我确实在一年前结婚了，几乎整整一年前。
Congrats.
恭喜。
And, um, you know, I got married at 49.
而且，嗯，你知道，我 49 岁结婚了。
I mean, I, I, it took me a while to both meet my wife and to, to almost be ready to get married.
我的意思是，我，我，我花了一段时间才见到我的妻子，并几乎准备好结婚。
And I had, without going too much into it.
我也做到了，但没有过多地关注它。
I had challenges in relationships.
我在人际关系方面遇到了挑战。
They were never, I found them easy to get into.
他们从来都不是，我发现他们很容易进入。
I found them hard to sustain.
我发现它们很难维持。
Let's just say that.
就这么说吧。
And a lot of that's between me and my therapist, but the journey of becoming the man who could stand in front of my wife and make that kind of commitment was quite a journey.
其中很多是我和我的治疗师之间的事情，但是成为一个能够站在我妻子面前并做出这种承诺的男人的旅程是一段相当长的旅程。
And I felt, and it was different.
我感觉到了，这是不同的。
Like I said, my challenges and relationships were different.
就像我说的，我的挑战和人际关系是不同的。
Like I used to joke with people that say, you know, Ted has to be careful not to get married on the first date, but I had to be careful not to get divorced on the first day.
就像我以前和人们开玩笑说，你知道，特德必须小心，不要在第一次约会时就结婚，但我必须小心，不要在第一天就离婚。
I was always like looking for the problem kind of thing, not like falling in love so quickly.
我总是喜欢寻找问题之类的事情，而不喜欢那么快坠入爱河。
But I think there's something about turning 50 having gotten married and just done some work around some of the shadowy aspects of playing Ted being thought of as a person that you're not, you know, some of that was really hard for me.
但我认为，在 50 岁结婚后，我只是做了一些工作，解决了扮演 Ted 时被认为是一个你不是的人的一些阴暗方面，你知道，其中一些对我来说真的很难。
It was really hard to navigate.
导航真的很难。
Just just in the realm of like identity.
只是在相似身份的领域里。
Like who am I?
比如我是谁？
Who do I self conceive of?
我自己设想的是谁？
Who do I think I am versus like all these people are telling me, you know, that's not your name your name is not Josh, you have to be rolling around New York City with Ted and Barney and you are, but Marshall and Barney and you are, you know, and it felt like this almost theft of my sense of self, like it was really a challenge.
我认为我是谁，就像所有这些人告诉我的那样，你知道，那不是你的名字，你的名字不是乔什，你必须和泰德和巴尼一起在纽约市转悠，而你是，但马歇尔和巴尼和你是，你知道，这感觉就像是我的自我意识几乎被盗，就像这真的是一个挑战。
But as the years have gone by, the people who say, I had a guy from Turkey yesterday, or two days ago, stopped me, came running out of coffee shop to stop me.
但随着时间的流逝，那些说“昨天或两天前有一个来自土耳其的人阻止了我”的人，从咖啡店跑出来阻止了我。
And he said, um, thank you so much for teaching us to believe in love, to believe in ourselves.
他说，嗯，非常感谢你教会我们相信爱，相信我们自己。
That's an amazing thing to hear on like a right morning, right?
听到这样的消息真是太棒了，就像一个正确的早晨，对吧？
11 in the morning.
上午11点。
Yeah.
是的。
And Jordan and my wife is really good at making me kind of pinch myself in those moments when she's with me like to say like, do you see that you are part something that really moved people.
乔丹和我的妻子真的很擅长让我在那些时刻掐自己，当她和我在一起的时候，她会说，你看到了吗，你是真正感动人们的一部分。
So the people who it's outweighed by you know any of that shadowy stuff is outweighed by the people who just say like you know like Rob Delaney in his book saying my wife and I needed to laugh and we watched how I met your mother when our son was sick in the hospital like things like that.
所以那些被你压倒的人知道，任何那些阴暗的东西都被那些像你知道的那样说的人压倒，就像罗伯·德莱尼在他的书中说我和我的妻子需要笑，我们看到当我们的儿子在医院生病时我是如何遇见你母亲的。
It's made me almost in like a like a Jungian way like to say All right, there's part of Ted that is, I wrote pretty extensively about this in my newsletter, but maybe a year or two ago, but about Ted's a part of me.
这让我几乎以一种荣格式的方式说，好吧，这是泰德的一部分，也就是说，我在我的时事通讯中写了相当多的内容，但也许是一两年前，但关于泰德是我的一部分。
He's literally a part I played, but he's not all of me.
他确实是我扮演的一个角色，但他并不是我的全部。
Yeah.
是的。
And I think for a long time, I was like trying to be like, that's not me, that's not me.
我想很长一段时间以来，我一直在努力表现出，那不是我，那不是我。
Like I was in rejection of him, but I would not take roles that evoked him, and I was really fighting him.
就像我在拒绝他，但我不会扮演那些能唤起他的角色，我真的是在和他作斗争。
And I think there's something about the time in my life right now, maybe it's just literally the mercy of time that has allowed me to say all right you know let's turn around and look at this guy let's look at this character you played let's look at who you were when you played this character and look I was a different person in 2005 then I was in 2014 and so are you a big time you know a lot yeah change and I'm a lot different now than I was in 2014 Yeah.
我认为现在我生命中的时间有些东西，也许正是时间的仁慈让我能够说，好吧，你知道，让我们转过身来看看这个家伙，让我们看看你扮演的这个角色，让我们看看当你扮演这个角色时你是谁，看看我在 2005 年是一个不同的人，然后是 2014 年，所以你是一个伟大的时代，你知道很多，是的，改变了，我现在和以前有很大不同。 2014 是啊。
So I think it was just, you know, there's something allowed me the space and the grace and the patience with myself to go, let's stop running away.
所以我认为这只是，你知道，有某种东西给了我空间、优雅和对自己的耐心，让我们停止逃跑。
Let's actually, this is a part, it's going to be in my obituary.
事实上，这是一部分，它将出现在我的讣告中。
A lot of people recognize me from it and still want to talk about it.
很多人从中认出了我，并且仍然想谈论它。
So I was just, I wanted to drop whatever war I had with it and just say, like, all right, how I made my mother, all right, Ted, let's take him, let's, let's bring it in.
所以我只是，我想放弃我与它之间的任何战争，只是说，好吧，我是如何创造我的母亲的，好吧，特德，让我们带上他，让我们，让我们把它带进来。
You know, bring it in.
你知道的，把它带进来。
Let's see what we, let's see what's there.
让我们看看我们有什么，让我们看看那里有什么。
Yeah, it's, and I, I hope that will make this little exploration, this experiment we're doing of this podcast, sort of universal to people, even if it's not like, the himium super fans.
是的，我，我希望这将使我们对这个播客所做的这个小小的探索，这个实验，对人们来说具有普遍性，即使它不像，himium 超级粉丝。
And like, well, I love that the himium super fans will listen, but it's also kind of a podcast about figuring out who you were in another chapter and how does it fit in with who you are now.
就像，嗯，我喜欢 Himium 超级粉丝会听，但这也是一个播客，旨在了解你在另一章中是谁以及它如何与你现在的身份相适应。
Yeah.
是的。
I mean, all the grand, all the grand themes of how I made my mother are at play right now in this podcast and they will be as long as we do it, you know, I do hope that there's people who've never watched the show, who tune into this podcast and watch it with us.
我的意思是，我如何塑造我母亲的所有宏伟主题现在都在这个播客中发挥作用，只要我们这样做，它们就会一直存在，你知道，我确实希望有人从未看过这个节目，他们会收听这个播客并与我们一起观看。
Yeah.
是的。
Okay.
好的。
Well, that brings me to my comment.
好吧，这引出了我的评论。
That brings me to a question.
这让我想到一个问题。
Yeah.
是的。
So Josh and I just played this wonderful chair.
所以乔什和我刚刚扮演了这把美妙的椅子。
And another thing that's emerged since how much your mother is that Josh Radner has become an amazing musician, singer, songwriter, and I have had the privilege of a few times now of playing music with him at these fan, fan-based fundraisers we do for a really important cause that I will talk about at some other point.
自从你母亲之后出现的另一件事是，乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）已经成为一位了不起的音乐家、歌手、词曲作者，我现在有幸在这些粉丝、基于粉丝的筹款活动中与他一起演奏音乐，我们是为了一个非常重要的事业而举办的，我将在其他时候谈论这一点。
And we just did it.
我们刚刚做到了。
a power ballroom, and it sold out a month early because how much your mother fans are the best, as I said.
一个强力舞厅，它提前一个月就卖完了，因为正如我所说，你妈妈的粉丝是最好的。
And two different people there afterwards, two different fans told me they had just watched the series 13 times over.
后来有两个不同的人，两个不同的粉丝告诉我他们刚刚把这个系列看了 13 遍。
They thought they watched it.
他们以为他们看了。
They just do the math on that.
他们只是对此进行数学计算。
My dream is trying to be 13 times 200 and failing.
我的梦想是尝试成为 13 乘以 200 的目标，但失败了。
I'm an English major.
我是英语专业的。
But it's a lot.
但数量很多。
And I, and thank you for watching it that much.
我，非常感谢您的观看。
I'm, well, you know, I haven't seen it that many times.
我，嗯，你知道，我还没有见过很多次。
I haven't done a rewinds in a long time.
我已经很久没有进行倒带了。
Here's my question, tell the fans, tell the people listening.
这是我的问题，告诉球迷，告诉听众。
How many times over has your wife, Jordana, seen how I met your mother?
你的妻子乔丹娜看过多少次我是如何遇见你母亲的？
Wow.
哇。
So yeah, Jordana, my wife, has seen how I met your mother is zero times.
所以，是的，乔丹娜，我的妻子，零次见过我是如何遇见你母亲的。
She's never seen the show, which was probably a help in our courtship.
她从未看过这个节目，这可能对我们的求爱有帮助。
I just want to say I find this so fascinating.
我只是想说我觉得这很有趣。
So what's happening here?
那么这里发生了什么？
I just want to lay it out for people.
我只是想把它摆出来给人们看。
Part of the reason we're doing this podcast is that you were talking to Jonathan about this and saying there's this crazy chapter of my life.
我们做这个播客的部分原因是你和乔纳森谈论了这件事，并说这是我生命中疯狂的一章。
You don't know anything about it.
你对此一无所知。
You worked for all they think that she didn't know anything about it because she just met you.
你为所有的事情付出了努力，他们认为她对此一无所知，因为她刚刚认识你。
Everything you just said about carrying Ted and wearing Ted on your face, she fell in love with you.
你刚才说的关于带着泰德、把泰德戴在脸上的一切，她都爱上了你。
She did not know what the hell how much your mother was, but still does not.
她不知道你妈妈到底多少钱，但现在仍然不知道。
You haven't started the read.
你还没有开始阅读。
And it's also crazy because she is a TV fan.
这也很疯狂，因为她是一个电视迷。
Yeah.
是的。
watch is a lot of shows.
看的是很多节目。
This one just I'm so the exp one of the experiments of this too is Josh will now sit down and it really like how I met your mother in the episode where Ted is dating Stella.
这只是我的实验之一，乔什现在会坐下来，这真的很像我在特德与斯特拉约会的那一集中遇见你母亲的方式。
She's a star.
她是一位明星。
Stella has Stella has not seen Star Wars and Ted is terrified to what if she watches Star Wars?
斯黛拉没有看过《星球大战》，泰德很害怕如果她看了《星球大战》怎么办？
One of my like go to one of my core movies and doesn't like it.
我的一个喜欢去看我的一部核心电影但不喜欢它。
do I have to break up with her?
我必须和她分手吗？
Forget that, that felt like high stakes in the moment when we're writing that as Star Wars nerds.
忘记这一点，当我们作为星球大战书呆子写这篇文章时，感觉就像是高风险。
But can you imagine the, the, you're going to sit and watch how I much of mother a decade of your life, we're going to sit and watch that with your wife.
但你能想象吗，你会坐下来，看着我如何照顾你生命中的十年，我们会和你的妻子一起坐下来观看。
Is there pressure?
有压力吗？
Will that be a fun watch?
这会是一块有趣的手表吗？
Or will you be sort of side-ingered going like is she liking this?
或者你会侧目说她喜欢这个吗？
I mean, I'm so fascinated by this.
我的意思是，我对此非常着迷。
Probably watch her watch it quite a bit.
可能看她看了很多次。
I will say our relationship could withstand her not liking it, but I don't, I suspect she's not going to not like it.
我会说我们的关系可以承受她不喜欢，但我不喜欢，我怀疑她不会不喜欢。
Is that right?
是这样吗？
Is that what I mean to say?
这就是我想说的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
She's a psychologist and she's incredibly obviously psychologically attuned.
她是一名心理学家，而且她在心理上有着令人难以置信的协调能力。
So she will understand the deeper aspects of the show for sure.
所以她肯定会理解这个节目的更深层次的方面。
But we are going to have a section, we haven't worked out exactly how to do it, but we have a section called questions and observations from a clinical psychologist relationship expert who's never seen how I met your mother who also happens to be married to Josh.
但是我们将有一个部分，我们还没有确切地弄清楚如何做到这一点，但是我们有一个称为问题和观察的部分，来自一位临床心理学家关系专家，他从未见过我是如何认识你母亲的，她也恰好与乔什结婚。
Is that title too catchy?
这标题是不是太吸引人了？
Because that's just what you get an acronym for.
因为这就是你得到的缩写。
Well, let's just get an acronym for it and we'll be able to.
好吧，我们只要得到它的缩写就可以了。
It's almost as good as Hwimium.
它几乎和 Hwimium 一样好。
Hwimium.
Hwimium。
Yeah.
是的。
I love that.
我喜欢那个。
I mean, my way for Becca, who, and I guess I should have said this the sooner.
我的意思是，我对贝卡的方式，我想我应该早点说这句话。
The two of us are kind of like Marshall and Lily, right?
我们两个有点像马歇尔和莉莉，对吧？
It's we met in Wesleyan University, we've been together that whole time.
我们是在卫斯理大学认识的，我们一直在一起。
And we were like the old married couple in our late 20s.
我们就像是二十多岁的老夫妻。
And that was part of the impetus of how I miss mother and the characters, the creation of those characters.
这也是我想念母亲和角色以及创造这些角色的部分动力。
She is so annoyed because she only ever watched every episode once.
她很生气，因为她只看过每一集一次。
And she said, here's how I watched every episode.
她说，这就是我观看每一集的方式。
It would be Monday night.
那是星期一晚上。
I would be airing.
我会播出。
You'd be sitting next to me, staring at me, if I laughed at the right spots, you would say did we sound mix that wrong?
你会坐在我旁边，盯着我，如果我在正确的地方笑，你会说我们听起来是不是混音错了？
You didn't hear, I think you didn't hear that line because you didn't laugh and she'd be like, I didn't laugh because it wasn't that great.
你没有听到，我想你没有听到那句话，因为你没有笑，她会说，我没有笑，因为那不是那么好。
It's not, it's not all gold.
不，不全是金子。
It's not all gold, dude.
这并不都是金子，伙计。
And I'd ask her, like, is the music too hot there compared to the dialogue?
我会问她，与对话相比，音乐是否太热了？
She'd be like, I don't, I don't care.
她会说，我不关心，我不在乎。
I just want to watch it.
我只是想看看。
Stop it.
停止吧。
So that was her great, she, she watched for nine years like that and has basically never seen episodes besides that.
那就是她太棒了,她她就这样看了九年了,基本上就没有看过除此之外的剧集了。
And she has been asking for years, like can we We died back in, can we do the rewatch?
她多年来一直在问，比如我们可以死回来吗，我们可以重看吗？
And I don't know, for whatever reason, I just didn't, I didn't do it.
我不知道，无论出于什么原因，我就是没有，我没有这样做。
I don't know why.
我不知道为什么。
Maybe I was waiting for a round number.
也许我正在等待一个整数。
I was waiting for these 10s and one of these probably- Well, you know, I know this from watching, you know, films I made, like you stopped thinking about the mix 10 years later.
我一直在等待这 10 部影片，其中一部可能是——嗯，你知道，我通过观看我制作的电影知道这一点，就像 10 年后你不再考虑混音一样。
Right.
正确的。
You know, you'll just- The bad joke.
你知道，你只会——那个糟糕的笑话。
You're like that joke.
你就像那个笑话。
Yeah.
是的。
That joke could have been funnier.
这个笑话本来可以更好笑。
And then you see it later and you're like, that was a good joke.
当你稍后看到它时，你会想，这是一个很好的笑话。
What the fuck is I talking about?
我他妈在说什么？
And this old man, he must did me, fell in love with you, knew you're a city.
而这个老人，他一定是做了我，爱上了你，知道你是一座城市。
And now, commercials!
现在，广告！
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the HyperFixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，HyperFixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
Problems like, I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York.
比如，我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车。
Or, why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
或者，为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that cause that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the HyperFixed Podcast from Radio Topia.
这是来自 Radio Topia 的 HyperFixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at HyperFixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 HyperFixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
End of commercials back to show.
广告结束返回放映。
But here's a thing that we were starting to unpack in a talk, but we said, ah, let's save it for the show.
但这是我们在一次演讲中开始解开的一件事，但我们说，啊，让我们把它留到节目中吧。
And we can also dip into this with Carter, but it's so fascinating to me that you guys were the age of the characters you were writing essentially.
我们也可以和卡特一起探讨这个问题，但这对我来说太有趣了，因为你们基本上就是你们所写角色的年龄。
Yeah.
是的。
And yet it was framed as a flashback from an older wiser man who was offering this kind of wisdom and perspective born of his years of being farther along and being able to look back and contextualize it.
然而，它被认为是一位年长智者的闪回，他提供了这种智慧和观点，这些智慧和观点源于他多年来的走得更远，能够回顾过去并将其置于背景中。
And so you were having to, from inside of the experience, you were having to almost beam your consciousness forward 20 or 25 years and reflect back on the moment you were in, which is like a heroic amount to ask, I think, of any one much less, you know, young kids running their first TV show, like, were you conscious of the weirdness of that?
所以你不得不，从经历的内部，你不得不几乎将你的意识向前投射20或25年，并反思你所处的那一刻，我认为，这对于任何一个更不用说的人来说，都是一个英雄般的问题，你知道，比如，你知道这有什么奇怪的吗？
It, well, it, it seems weirder now in a way.
它，呃，它，现在在某种程度上看起来更奇怪了。
It almost didn't seem that weird at the time.
当时看起来几乎没有那么奇怪。
And I, I think it's because we fancied ourselves, older and wiser than our ears.
而我，我想这是因为我们幻想自己比我们的耳朵更古老、更聪明。
Right.
正确的。
I think I, yeah, we were like, we were like, 32 writing 52 or something, right?
我想我，是的，我们就像，我们就像，32 写 52 之类的，对吧？
When we were writing, thinking about future Ted's perspectives and his, and his mid fifties, whatever he is, we're now far closer to that.
当我们写作时，思考未来特德的观点和他的观点，以及他五十多岁的观点，无论他是什么，我们现在已经更接近那个目标了。
And I look back at it and I do think it had something to do with wanting, being drawn to the idea of reassurance of the future.
回顾过去，我确实认为这与想要、被对未来放心的想法所吸引有关。
There's a future you, because you feel so lost when you're 30, right?
未来的你是有的，因为30岁的时候你会感到很失落，对吗？
You just, you're not, you're not actually quite an adult, right?
你只是，你不是，你实际上还不是一个成年人，对吧？
We were, we all felt like fraud, so we were all the same age, we're all these little kids.
我们都觉得自己像个骗子，所以我们都是同龄人，我们都是小孩子。
We somehow fooled our way into having a TV show.
我们不知何故搞了一个电视节目。
And like we, I think we were just imagining our future selves telling us what we wanted to here now, in this moment, because we felt lost, because we felt scared, because we felt haunted.
就像我们一样，我认为我们只是想象未来的自己告诉我们现在想要什么，此时此刻，因为我们感到失落，因为我们感到害怕，因为我们感到困扰。
And that idea of that future Ted gave us so much confidence.
特德对未来的想法给了我们很大的信心。
Like it just, it sort of lifted us up to be looking through that lens.
就像它一样，它有点让我们通过这个镜头来观察。
And we, by, by pretending to be that thing, we sort of became that thing.
而我们，通过假装成为那个东西，我们就变成了那个东西。
And that's so great.
那真是太棒了。
Now we're sort of the age, almost the age of the, of future Ted.
现在我们已经进入了这个时代，几乎是未来特德的时代。
And I still feel just about as confused as I ever did about life, but I feel, I feel a little older and a little wiser.
我仍然像以前一样对生活感到困惑，但我感觉，我感觉自己老了一点，聪明了一点。
And I think another big part of it was we were aware, we were, Carter and I, we were big thinkers, we're overthinkers, and we were very aware that a chapter of our lives had ended.
我认为另一个重要原因是我们意识到，卡特和我，我们是伟大的思想家，我们是过度思考者，我们非常清楚我们生命中的一个章节已经结束了。
The 20s in New York part had ended.
20 世纪 20 年代的纽约部分已经结束。
We were writers for David Letterman, and we made this leap, and this will be a very heavy thing to bring up and talk about it, sitcom, but we, you know, 9-11 happened a little bit before, like that happened right before we moved to LA.
我们是大卫·莱特曼的编剧，我们实现了这一飞跃，提起并谈论它，情景喜剧，这将是一件非常沉重的事情，但我们，你知道，9-11 事件发生过一段时间，就像我们搬到洛杉矶之前发生的那样。
And this is feeling in New York City sort of writ large that something had ended, some era had ended, something had changed that was not going to change back.
在纽约市，这种感觉显而易见，有些事情已经结束，某个时代已经结束，有些事情已经发生了变化，而且不会再变回来。
And then we found ourselves living in Los Angeles trying to think of a pilot idea to write.
然后我们发现自己住在洛杉矶，试图想出一个写作的试点想法。
And we wrote about this nostalgia for our 20s in New York when we were like 30 and one day old.
我们写了关于我们 20 多岁时在纽约的怀旧之情，当时我们才 30 岁零一天。
We did, we were in the nostalgic for our 20s in New York immediately.
我们做到了，我们立即怀念 20 多岁的纽约时光。
And but nostalgic for like a time before this horrible tragedy hadn't happened, right?
但怀念这起可怕的悲剧没有发生之前的一段时光，对吧？
We were still writing for Letterman when 9-11 happened, and then we left to move to LA the spring after that, like the spring of 2002, and I just think the sort of grabby tasks and the instant requirement to become more of a grown-up from living through 9-11 in New York and the instant nostalgia and the desire to sort of have things make sense or be back in some simpler time and have it a different time in your brain and your memories when things didn't feel the way they felt after none of them.
9-11事件发生时，我们还在为莱特曼写作，然后我们离开并搬到了洛杉矶，那之后的春天，就像2002年的春天，我只是想到那种令人抓狂的任务，以及从在纽约经历了9-11事件后变得更加成熟的即时要求，以及即时的怀旧情绪和渴望让事情变得有意义，或者回到某个更简单的时间，当事情不像他们所感觉的那样时，在你的大脑和记忆中度过一个不同的时间在他们都没有之后。
And I think that we'd be really informed this show.
我认为我们会通过这个节目真正了解情况。
It made us like maybe a little older than our years and it made us a little more reflective, a little more nostalgic.
它让我们感觉自己比实际年龄老了一点，也让我们更加反思，更加怀旧。
And I think part of that is how we accessed writing from that future perspective even when we were in our 30s and were pretending to be the old wise guy.
我认为部分原因是我们如何从未来的角度进行写作，即使我们已经 30 多岁，假装自己是个老智者。
But somehow we could sort of fake our way into being that at least on paper.
但不知何故，我们可以假装成为这样的人，至少在纸面上是这样。
And I sometimes people will quote months from future Ted to me and say that got them through a really hard time.
有时人们会向我引用未来泰德几个月的经历，并说这让他们度过了一段非常艰难的时期。
Thank you for those wise words.
谢谢你那些明智的话。
And I'm talking we were like 31 wishing we had that wisdom and sort of like play acting it.
我想说的是，我们就像 31 岁的人一样希望自己拥有这种智慧，并且有点像演戏一样。
But it works somehow right?
但它确实有效，对吗？
It feels to me like like Kenneth Branagh at 31 playing Lear and you're like, what are you doing?
对我来说，这就像 31 岁的肯尼思·布拉纳 (Kenneth Branagh) 扮演《李尔王》一样，你会想，你在做什么？
But also it's like he's good at it.
但也好像他很擅长。
Right.
正确的。
You know, and it sort of, and does it, does it elevate you?
你知道，这有点，它确实提升了你吗？
It's sort of that idea of like the fake until you make a thing, like it somehow it elevated us and made us feel like we really were that older, was it?
这有点像假货，直到你做出了一件东西，就像它以某种方式提升了我们，让我们感觉自己真的那么老了，是吗？
You know, speaking of, uh, of Jordan, who it seems like we're we talking about a bit, she has a thing which she'll sometimes say to her patients.
你知道，说到乔丹，我们似乎正在谈论她，她有时会对她的病人说一些话。
If someone's really confused, really tied in knots about something, she'll say, what is your 85 year old self say?
如果有人真的很困惑，真的对某事纠结不已，她会说，你85岁的自己会说什么？
She's going to like him in.
她会喜欢他的。
She didn't like the show.
她不喜欢这个节目。
Yeah.
是的。
question.
问题。
And she said, if you ask yourself, what is my 85 year old self, the answer comes real fast.
她说，如果你问自己，85 岁的我是什么样子，答案很快就会出来。
And it's real service.
这是真正的服务。
And I think, you know, I mentioned this in that piece I wrote about Ted for my muse letters, but Dick Schwartz has this thing, internal family systems, IFS, which is like really, it's called parts work.
我想，你知道，我在为我的缪斯信写的关于泰德的那篇文章中提到了这一点，但迪克施瓦茨有这个东西，内部家庭系统，IFS，这就像真的，它被称为零件工作。
And you're locating these parts of yourself that are sometimes at odds with each other, but they're all in you.
你会发现自己的这些部分有时会互相矛盾，但它们都在你身上。
And it strikes me that you and Carter like, like, and me too, we have an elder in us.
让我印象深刻的是，你和卡特喜欢，喜欢，我也喜欢，我们有一位长辈。
We have an older, I don't know if it's ancestral or just a wise old, something connected more towards the bigger picture, the perennial kind of wisdom, and we can go there.
我们有一个更年长的人，我不知道它是祖传的还是只是一个智慧的老人，与更大的图景有更多的联系，永恒的智慧，我们可以去那里。
We can access it at 31 or 30 whenever you guys were writing.
当你们写作时，我们可以在 31 或 30 访问它。
The other thing that, I don't know if it was you or Carter, but first season, what year was older Ted narrating 2030?
另外，我不知道是你还是卡特，但第一季中，老泰德讲述的2030年是哪一年？
2030, yeah.
2030 年，是的。
2030.
2030年。
So one of you guys said, it's actually the most optimistic show in the world because it's saying the world will still be here in 2030.
所以你们中的一个人说，这实际上是世界上最乐观的节目，因为它说世界到 2030 年仍然如此。
Like they'll still be fathers talking to their kids in 2030.
就像到 2030 年他们仍然是父亲一样与孩子交谈。
Yeah.
是的。
And we would make the joke because it is inspiring to think of and that we'd make the joke.
我们会开这个玩笑，因为它令人鼓舞，我们会开这个玩笑。
But also like we can end the series where you realize like Ted is telling future Ted is telling his kids that story like a mile underground the surface of the earth and I'm like he's gonna take that to the surface and it's just like the machines have risen up and killed us.
但就像我们可以结束这个系列一样，你会意识到泰德正在告诉未来，泰德正在告诉他的孩子们这个故事，就像地球表面地下一英里一样，我想他会把这个故事带到地表，就像机器已经崛起并杀死了我们一样。
But yeah like that idea there will always be future you there to tell you.
但是，是的，就像这个想法一样，未来的你总会在那里告诉你。
There's that future version of you to whom this all makes more sense and that is just So so much more generous and has such gratitude for even the low moments looking back.
对未来的你来说，这一切都更有意义，而且更加慷慨，即使是回顾低潮的时刻，也会充满感激之情。
Yeah.
是的。
I think the the thing you're describing that I think opened my heart the most to the series.
我认为你所描述的事情最让我对这个系列敞开心扉。
And I don't know how much I sense from the pilot, but I think it's all there.
我不知道我从飞行员身上感受到了多少，但我想一切都在那里。
The DNA of the whole show is in the pilot, which we'll be unpacking.
整个节目的 DNA 都在试播集中，我们将对其进行解压。
Yeah.
是的。
But it's an it's a fundamentally optimistic show at its core.
但这本质上是一部乐观的剧。
It is not a nihilistic cynical show, it's a show about decent people.
这不是一个虚无主义的愤世嫉俗的节目，这是一个关于正派人的节目。
And even Barney, who's like somewhat of a sociopathic criminal based on episode, you know, whatever episode he's in, has a core of sweetness about him.
甚至巴尼，根据剧集来看，他有点像一个反社会的罪犯，你知道，无论他在哪一集，他都有一个甜蜜的核心。
Yeah.
是的。
And the way Neil played it kind of with a wink that maybe helped him get away.
尼尔眨眼的方式可能帮助他逃脱。
You guys all get away with a lot.
你们都逃脱了很多。
But it's a fundamentally optimistic show.
但这从根本上来说是一个乐观的节目。
And I just, I liked being both for professional reasons but more almost like for personal reasons like I'm really conscious of what I'm putting into the collective like I want and you know how I made your mother made some missteps and stumbles and we're going to unpack all of those but generally I felt like it's it's feet were pointed in a really good direction and it's heart was in the right place also how narratively invented it was you know there were something like 40 to 60 scenes in an average, I don't know if it's worth.
我只是，我喜欢两者都是出于职业原因，但更接近于个人原因，比如我真的很清楚我要像我想要的那样将什么放入集体中，你知道我是如何让你母亲犯下一些错误和绊脚的，我们将解开所有这些，但总的来说，我觉得它的脚指向一个非常好的方向，它的心在正确的位置，还有它是如何叙事性发明的，你知道一个电影中有大约 40 到 60 个场景。中等，不知道值不值。
The record was 80, the record was 83.
纪录是80，纪录是83。
In 21 minutes, 21 and a half minutes basically, you're doing 81 scenes or 60 scenes or 50 scenes, like it's a lot.
基本上，在 21 分钟、21 分半钟的时间里，你要拍 81 个场景、60 个场景或 50 个场景，好像很多。
Alec, you have a question.
亚历克，你有一个问题。
By the way, I will say Alec Lev is chiming in a little comment.
顺便说一下，我想说亚历克·列夫（Alec Lev）正在插话。
Alec worked on the show multiple seasons as our new media coordinator.
亚历克作为我们的新媒体协调员参与了该剧多个季的工作。
He did the in production podcast, which we did for a few years on the show and he did all the sort of internet presence and DVD extras and all the stuff.
他制作了制作中的播客，我们在节目中做了几年，他还制作了所有的互联网节目和 DVD 附加节目以及所有的东西。
So Alec is also a himium alone, which I failed to say.
所以亚历克也是一个孤独的人，这一点我没有说。
Alec, what do you want to say?
亚历克，你想说什么？
And you and I also shared a cat that we went to college and lived together all four years.
你和我还共用一只猫，我们上大学并一起生活了四年。
And one time I was hanging out with Alec and a bunch of people and he said, he introduced me forgetting that we went to college together and he started explaining what Wesleyan is.
有一次我和亚历克以及一群人一起出去玩，他说，他介绍我时忘记了我们一起上过大学，然后他开始解释什么是卫斯理安。
He said to other people that we were standing with, they went to us and he was like, we all went to college together, Wesleyan.
他对其他人说，我们和我们站在一起，他们走向我们，他说，我们一起上大学，卫斯理安。
I'm like, yeah, asshole.
我就像，是的，混蛋。
I was, I lived there.
我是，我住在那里。
You don't have to tell me that.
你不必告诉我这一点。
Anyways, Alec, go ahead.
无论如何，亚历克，继续吧。
Well, no, I just want to so this podcast, I want to hear a little bit as we wrap up this first episode of what people can expect from this version of a rewatch podcast.
好吧，不，我只是想让这个播客，在我们结束第一集时，我想听听一些关于人们可以从这个版本的重播播客中期待什么的内容。
If you've heard other ones where people go episode by episode, we are going to do that.
如果你听说过其他人一集一集地观看的内容，我们就会这样做。
Next week you're going to hear Carter Bay, as we've talked a lot about Carter, Carter's going to join us to talk about the creation of how I met your mother and all these questions that you guys have been asking.
下周你们将听到卡特·贝的讲话，因为我们已经谈论了很多关于卡特的事情，卡特将和我们一起谈论我如何认识你们母亲的故事以及你们一直在问的所有这些问题。
And then from there, we'll be going episode by episode because you talk a little bit about about what people are going to hear that you know of, because of course, we don't quite know where we're going, exactly, but Josh, talk a little bit about what's coming up.
然后从那里开始，我们将一集接着一集，因为你会谈论一些你知道的人们会听到的内容，因为当然，我们不太知道我们要去哪里，确切地说，但是乔什，谈论一下即将发生的事情。
Yeah, I know this is a big fun trend that people are really liking these rewatch podcasts.
是的，我知道这是一个很有趣的趋势，人们真的很喜欢这些重看播客。
I have to confess, I've never listened to a single one of them.
我必须承认，我从来没有听过他们中的任何一首。
I don't know, I know it's happening.
我不知道，我知道它正在发生。
I don't know what other people are doing.
我不知道其他人在做什么。
I just know what I like to talk about with Craig.
我只知道我喜欢和克雷格谈论什么。
I have, and Craig has some special insight into this particular show, I think that some episodes will be more very specifically about the episode.
我有，而且克雷格对这个特定的节目有一些特殊的见解，我认为某些剧集将更具体地介绍该剧集。
I imagine, you know, when we get to drumroll please, right?
我想，你知道，当我们开始击鼓时，对吧？
We'll like talk very deeply about that episode.
我们想深入讨论那一集。
It's a pretty iconic one.
这是一个非常具有标志性的。
I remember, I think this is true that they could analyze the data, like once it went up maybe on Netflix and drumroll please was the one that was like the hookiest episode.
我记得，我认为这是真的，他们可以分析数据，就像一旦它出现在Netflix上，请鼓乐就像是最挂钩的一集。
Like it was the one that made people to watch more or something.
就像它让人们观看更多或其他东西一样。
I don't know.
我不知道。
That's right.
这是正确的。
But then there are other ones that maybe are a little less dense that might just inspire another talk.
但还有其他一些可能不太密集的内容可能会激发另一场谈话。
So if you're tuning in with us, you're going to hear a lot of talk about how I mean, but you're also going to hear us muse about different things.
因此，如果您收听我们的节目，您会听到很多关于我的意思的讨论，但您也会听到我们对不同事物的思考。
I want us to be open to talk about our own lives, to talk about it's not going to be super current a Pharisee because I think like one of the things I love about how I made other mother is the part of it that ages well in terms of you know it wasn't there wasn't a lot of tech in how I made well I mean it was things that that will be perennially relevant right.
我希望我们能够开诚布公地谈论我们自己的生活，谈论这不会成为法利赛人的流行，因为我认为我喜欢的关于我如何成为另一个母亲的事情之一是它的一部分，因为你知道，我的成功并不是没有太多的技术，我的意思是这些事情将永远相关，对吧。
So I think we if you want to watch along or rewatch along with us there's going to be a lot of talk about certain episodes, certain jokes where it came to funny off-stage anecdotes, anecdotes, inside baseball stuff that will be really fun for the superfan, but also, I hope it's just a fun, you know, getting to spend some time with us, you know, in a way that feels nourishing and insightful, and just like a breezy good time, you know.
所以我想，如果你想和我们一起观看或重看的话，将会有很多关于某些剧集、某些笑话的讨论，其中涉及有趣的台下轶事、轶事、棒球内部的东西，这对超级粉丝来说真的很有趣，而且，我希望这只是一种乐趣，你知道，与我们一起度过一些时间，你知道，以一种感觉滋养和富有洞察力的方式，就像一段轻松愉快的时光，你知道。
Yeah, and I think there's going to be some looking back with different eyes.
是的，我认为会有一些人用不同的眼光回顾过去。
I think there'll be some owning of some moments that didn't age as well.
我认为，我们会拥有一些不那么古老的时刻。
Even though I hope the show is timeless, I think there's going to be some a few like apologies to people whose stories we stole without asking.
尽管我希望这个节目是永恒的，但我认为对于那些我们未经询问就窃取了故事的人，我认为会有一些类似的道歉。
I was terrible at that.
我对此感到很糟糕。
I would just take people's life stories.
我只会拍摄人们的生活故事。
I'd be like, that's funny.
我会想，这很有趣。
Put it on TV and then I wouldn't tell the person that's in TV.
把它放在电视上，然后我就不会告诉电视里的人。
Until they saw it.
直到他们看到了。
What the hell is going on here?
这到底是怎么回事？
So if you're wondering where he got the idea for a married couple sharing a toothbrush, just tune it.
所以，如果你想知道他从哪里得到了一对已婚夫妇共用牙刷的想法，那就调整一下吧。
Well, uh, we'll, we'll, we'll dive into that one.
嗯，呃，我们会，我们会，我们会深入研究这个问题。
Spoilers, it's Alex.
剧透，这是亚历克斯。
I mean, let's just let's just let's just let's go there.
我的意思是，我们就去那里吧。
Why are we going to wait?
我们为什么要等待？
Someone watched it and said, it's pronounced chameleon.
有人看了就说，这叫变色龙。
Oh my God, I definitely want to talk about that one.
天哪，我绝对想谈谈这个。
Um, but yeah, yeah, I think it's going to, it's going to be fun.
嗯，但是是的，是的，我想这会很有趣。
It's going to be fun to look back on it.
回顾起来会很有趣。
And sometimes it'll be very much about the episode, sometimes a little bit spuous, like, what, what, what, what, what did, What did the topic of that episode make us think about at the time and now?
有时它会非常关于这一集，有时有点虚假，比如，什么，什么，什么，什么，做了什么，那集的主题让我们在当时和现在思考什么？
And how do we look at it now and how much I want to talk also about what of our lives at the time made it onto the show.
现在我们如何看待它，我是多么想谈谈我们当时的生活是什么进入了节目。
And what it was happening in our own personal lives that informed the show.
以及我们个人生活中发生的事情为这部剧提供了信息。
Like I, yeah, I went through a lot during how much your mother, as did we all in nine years, you go through a lot of stuff and basically 10 years door to door.
就像我一样，是的，我在你母亲的过程中经历了很多，就像我们在九年里一样，你经历了很多事情，基本上是十年挨家挨户的经历。
And yeah, I want to talk about that stuff.
是的，我想谈谈这些事情。
And also how you as writers start paying attention very keenly to us as actors and how that changes how you write the character.
以及作为作家的你如何开始非常敏锐地关注我们作为演员，以及这如何改变你写角色的方式。
You know, there were certain things I remember, I remember like sometimes you'll get a big laugh at a run-through, like a network run-through, and I'll just be like, oh, they're gonna, and I remember when I walked in return of the shirt, which for some reason I have very big fondness for.
你知道，有些事情我记得，我记得有时你会在一次连贯中大笑，就像网络连贯，我会说，哦，他们会的，我记得当我走回衬衫时，出于某种原因我非常喜欢这件衬衫。
But when I walked in and Marshall said, Hot top, bro.
但当我走进去时，马歇尔说，热顶，兄弟。
Do you remember that?
你还记得吗？
And I just said, right, right.
我只是说，对，对。
And for some reason, right, right became a kind of, it was like a catchphrase.
由于某种原因，对，对成为一种，就像一个流行语。
It was a low key catchphrase.
这是一个低调的口号。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And I think that was one of the first times I said, but I remember people just, I say that all the time, just like laughed so hard as they're right, right?
我想这是我第一次这么说，但我记得人们，我一直这么说，就像笑得很厉害，因为他们是对的，对吧？
We did that all the time.
我们一直都是这么做的。
That is a, like, if that, that's a low key.
这是一个，如果那样的话，那就是低调。
I mean, catchphrase.
我的意思是，口号。
I'm glad you put it that one out.
我很高兴你把它拿出来了。
I definitely still say that.
我肯定还是这么说。
And that was, that was your, did you improvise that?
那是，那是你的，是你即兴创作的吗？
I don't feel like we were to be right I don't remember I have we might have written it But I have one in my mind what people say did you ever write on the show and I said One line and it was I Dropped what was the thing where I had to climb in the mailbox and I got stuck in the mailbox What was that literally blanking on what the context of the New York street and I dropped in a letter to the mailbox And then I realized that I needed to get it out.
我不觉得我们是对的，我不记得我们可能写过它，但我心里有一个想法，人们说你在节目中写过什么，我说一行，那是我把我必须爬进邮箱的东西扔进了邮箱，我被困在邮箱里，纽约街道的背景是什么，我把一封信扔到邮箱里，然后我意识到我需要把它拿出来。
I shouldn't have mailed it But I remember I, I, I did the rehearsal and I went up to either you or Carter whoever was on set and I said, can I drop it in and say, mailed it?
我不应该邮寄它，但我记得我，我，我排练过，我去找你或卡特，无论是谁在片场，我说，我可以把它放进去并说，邮寄它吗？
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
That was my one big improv that made it.
这是我做出的一大改进。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
I just speak that.
我只是说说而已。
I feel like there were many more than that, but that's a good.
我觉得还有很多，但这是一件好事。
Oh, maybe, maybe.
哦，也许，也许。
Yeah.
是的。
So I just want to add here about all the ways that listeners can interact with the show because from the very beginning, you've both been saying you want this very much to be a show for not just for the fans, but sort of buy them as well.
所以我只想在这里补充一下听众与节目互动的所有方式，因为从一开始，你们就一直在说，你们非常希望这不仅是一场为粉丝而做的节目，而且也为他们买单。
And if you go to our website, how we made your mother.com, you're going to find a way that you can send us a message and tell us your story.
如果您访问我们的网站，了解我们如何创建您的 mother.com，您将找到一种可以向我们发送消息并告诉我们您的故事的方法。
And you can tell us a story just about how I met your mother in general or there's even ways for you to talk about specific episodes, send in an audio message to us, like you heard at the beginning of this show.
你可以告诉我们一个关于我如何认识你母亲的故事，或者甚至可以让你谈论特定的情节，向我们发送音频消息，就像你在节目开始时听到的那样。
You can also write us a message and we'll read a lot of those like a lot of them like we really want to hear from you.
您也可以给我们留言，我们会阅读很多信息，就像我们真的很想收到您的来信一样。
Also, the home of this show online is really going to be on substack and you can find a link to that on our website.
此外，该在线节目的主页实际上将位于子堆栈上，您可以在我们的网站上找到该链接。
Josh is on substack and you can read his newsletters and then you'll also be able to read about the show.
乔什在子堆栈上，您可以阅读他的时事通讯，然后您还可以阅读有关该节目的信息。
Josh and Craig are going to write a little bit about each episode.
乔什和克雷格将针对每一集写一些内容。
You'll get the show notes there and maybe other ways to interact and of course were all over social media.
你会在那里得到演出笔记，也许还有其他互动方式，当然还有社交媒体。
So if you just go over to how we made your mother.com and you're going to find all of those ways to be a part of how we made your mother.
因此，如果您回顾一下我们如何创建您的 mother.com，您就会发现所有这些方法都成为我们创建您母亲的一部分。
Yeah, and we really want to encourage people to kind of like join the community of this thing and kind of, you know, collect an archive of them.
是的，我们真的想鼓励人们加入这个东西的社区，并收集它们的档案。
Like this is, this is, this is what the show is and was and remains to us.
就像这样，这就是，这就是这个节目对我们来说是、过去和现在的样子。
But we love the idea of you guys feeling like it's, it's, It's us doing this, but you're with us, you know?
但我们喜欢这样的想法：你们感觉是，是的，是我们在做这件事，但你们和我们在一起，知道吗？
So participate, join us, tell your friends, we're really excited.
所以参与进来，加入我们，告诉你的朋友，我们真的很兴奋。
We're soliciting kind of testimonials about how I met your mother and what it's meant to people.
我们正在征求有关我如何认识你母亲以及这对人们意味着什么的推荐。
And that we really want this to be a feature of the show.
我们真的希望这成为该剧的一个特色。
We want to hear from you out there, how you discovered the show, what it's meant to you.
我们想听听您的意见，您是如何发现这个节目的，它对您意味着什么。
So I'm just going to read one because maybe we'll make this a regular feature.
所以我只想读一篇，因为也许我们会让它成为一项常规功能。
But this one says, hey Josh, I'm sending you this message from France.
但这个人说，嘿乔希，我从法国给你发了这条消息。
I don't know if you really love being recognized this Ted Mosby, but today I want to talk to you about it.
我不知道你是否真的喜欢被认出是特德·莫斯比，但今天我想和你谈谈。
I need to talk to you about it because tonight for the third time I finished how I met your mother and for the third time I cried a lot.
我需要和你谈谈这件事，因为今晚我第三次讲完我是如何遇见你母亲的，第三次我哭了很多。
I'm 17 and I really grew up watching this series and I mean in every way possible.
我今年 17 岁，我真的是看着这个系列节目长大的，我的意思是在所有可能的方面。
I went through a lot of very bad times and you were always there to make me laugh and believe again, you were there to instruct me really important things about life, every episode had something to teach me.
我经历了很多非常糟糕的时光，你总是在那里让我欢笑并再次相信，你在那里指导我关于生活的真正重要的事情，每一集都有一些东西可以教给我。
Like I, just like your character, believe a lot in destiny, maybe too much.
就像我，就像你的性格一样，非常相信命运，也许是太过分了。
I love too much.
我太爱了。
I do everything too much.
我做的一切都太多了。
And sometimes I'm worrying if I shouldn't just stop.
有时我会担心我是否不应该停下来。
But thanks to how I met your mother, I'll never worry again because this is me and I'm never gonna change.
但多亏了我认识你母亲的方式，我再也不会担心了，因为这就是我，我永远不会改变。
I'll still be me forever.
我永远还是我。
So what I want to say is a big thank you, Josh, everything.
所以我想说的是，非常感谢你，乔什，一切。
By the way, I listened to your songs and they are a legend.
顺便说一下，我听过你的歌，它们是一个传奇。
Wait for it, Derry.
等等，德里。
So that's awesome.
所以这太棒了。
Yeah.
是的。
I like to pick that one.
我喜欢选那个。
I don't want it to seem like I was like, let's pick the one where they mentioned my music.
我不想让别人觉得我在想，让我们选一个他们提到我的音乐的吧。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请装备我。
All sins off again.
一切罪孽再次消散。
New York City.
纽约市。
How we made your mother is hosted an executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯担任执行制片人主持。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, artwork by John Morrow.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves，作品由 John Morrow 设计。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）创作的《NYC》。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit howwemajormother.com to sign up for our Substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
请访问 howwemajormother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表以及我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您还可以单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯。
Read Craig Thomas' published prose at CraigThomasRider.com, and you can subscribe to my Dead Father Society, also on Substack.
阅读克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 在 CraigThomasRider.com 上发表的散文，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》(Dead Father Society)。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for a congenital heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解如何做出改变，这显示了正在进行的为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
This episode was made possible by the support of backyard ventures, marketing provided by Tink Media.
这一集是在 Backyard Ventures 的支持和 Tink Media 的营销支持下得以实现的。
will in fact dance.
事实上会跳舞。
Well Craig, thank you for chatting with me my friend, this is a delight.
克雷格，谢谢你和我聊天，我的朋友，这很高兴。
This is a delight.
这是一件令人高兴的事。
If not one person listens, I'm still having a really good time, but let's do it 220 more times.
即使没有人听，我仍然玩得很开心，但我们再做 220 次吧。
Let's do it at least.
至少让我们这样做吧。
At least 310s 13.
至少 310s 13.
Yeah, but it's a delight to spend time with you and Alec and I'm excited to unpack this stuff.
是的，但很高兴能与你和亚历克共度时光，我很高兴能打开这些东西。
And it feels honestly, it feels like psychologically healthy for me to do this, you know.
老实说，这样做对我来说感觉心理健康，你知道。
It feels like, are you ready to go back to the Titanic?
感觉就像，你准备好回到泰坦尼克号了吗？
It's got a kind of quality of that, but I am, you know, let's do it.
它有这样的品质，但我，你知道，让我们这么做吧。